I am human and nothing of that which is
human is alien to me this was written
nearly 2,000 years ago by Terrance a
Roman playwright and a freed slave but
these words are still relevant
so then how did we get here even after
all this time we've become more educated
but never learn I am human and you're
human no matter what happens between us
that is our bond that links us despite
religious beliefs or political
allegiance despite everything we point
out and label different we've lost sight
of the bigger picture the truth is we're
all we've got
we are different but we are human people
say all lives matter but actions speak
louder than words
heads up don't shoot those are too often
someone's last words all lives matter
when black lives matter we yearn for
connection but build walls where bridges
belong we've broken our promises we
allow corporations to poison our water
we need a protest to make it a priority
but what we reap is what we sow these
hands are as wide as they come but even
I know they come from the hands of
immigrants though not all immigrants
face the same barriers all want the same
acceptance do not justify hatred do not
normalize bigotry instead let us fight
for love fight for each other
history repeats itself but does it have
to it all depends on the choices we make
take time to reflect until no hope
becomes no fear let this be the call I
am human art I am human I am human I am
human I am human I'm a human being and
so are you
you